皆さんいいかー持ってますでしょうか
生音源ミュージック好きな人だったらタブスピーカーとかイヤホンとか本当にこだわる
と思うんですよ僕はこだわり有りませんことに全くないんですけどもせっかく東京の
この号雑なお家にいるのであればただしビーカーも値段どんどん積めば積むほどすごい
奴になるんじゃねっていうことでありましたと
最強のスピーカーありました最高のスピーカーこれもスピーカーと言っていいのか
わからないんですけどめっちゃスピーカーらしいので後を買ってみたんですけどもまぁ
値段もね業者の方に聞いてみようと思います
まずですごいですよスピーカーとは何かとなりますからスピーカーを多くとかそういう
概念じゃなくてスピーカーに入るそういう考えのスピーカーが打ってよろしいんです
けどようやく
今日届きましたので設定
[音楽]
でゲーもう内の銀貨がぴったりウマなくらい
税経
スピーカーぬーっに if ぴ
はですよねそう品っていうか巨大ねえブルー
強大な av るーうわぁ
スタッフだこれはこれが土台となるんですよねーっ
めっちゃ思えを勢いつに入らない段ボール初めてです誰も存在したよー
ああああああああ
[音楽]
voodoo
石膏型終わりましたあ
ありがとうございます南北ちょっとまだ見てないんで見てみる
者にあのお値段の方を結果は98万円っています
90髪は100万円
私は早速家
福前の水がいい
を最強ですよねまあそうですね世界最強だといいやー
僕は見ま
[音楽]
大
なるほどすぞマルイですねこれを書いてんじゃんですそれじゃあございますん
あっはぁっ
ua すごいこれがスピーカーですか
14個のスピーカーが入ってるけどデザインを
委員会に行った者きゃ選挙下手になるんです
卵みたいですね a など近未来感が増しましたねー
本ほどこのいい結構の金見ないようモチーフに作っていただいたんですけど a
お腹もこれも全部スピーカーんはなんかすごいなぁ
おおもう母せすげー
あと飛沫カー然予防もできているフってこういうことですよねぇー
なんか入ると針の総務系てきて確かに自分の世界
まあ鯉がちょっとあんな聞こえないですよ校数
すごい一つ何か聞いてみてもいいですか
これのすごさを体感できるんですよね行ってみたいなまあと max チャット等甘く
見てたのですまったく
line 等ですね
終わって戻ってすごいですよ
これ皆さんに伝わるか分からないんですけどすごいですよもう
i am
car
すげー
中に入るとすごいねもう306 s とか音が来てて
10てよもうバレバレなんけどはマッドマックスめちゃくちゃグロいシーンですねこれ
はたゆえ東京のぼくのおうちに磨きがかかります
あっほんとゲームやっとっ恋立体音響で映画関係でみたいだし
俺は100万円かけ買ってよかったなと思いました一人なんで女連れ
この時に一緒に見れないのが非常に残念です一人でもゲームしたりアニメ映画観る分で
も最高ですマジで嫌
[音楽]
ブーブー言っ
うっうードゥ
[音楽]
いやー
すごいな伝わる
スピーカ14個から聞こえてるせもうあの音楽がこれすごいっすよ
[音楽]
知ってねー